let's go next to Tristan from Oregon
Tristan welcome to the program
can you hear me yes I can
hi David
um it's been a long time since I've
called your show I'm I'm the blind guy
who called your show a couple years ago
during the height of the pandemic I was
uh dealing with some back backlog
grocery issues at the time okay
great to hear from you again oh thank
you thank you um so two questions one's
much more relevant relevant than the
other
um
I know on one of your recent streams you
you said that you were a fan of
chocolate vodka I just got recently
introduced to the world of chocolate
vodka via Trader Joe's and I just wanted
to get your opinion like is that Trader
Joe's chocolate Bobcat any good
I have no idea I've never had it I've
never had it
um you know I I do think that I don't
know what the situation necessarily is
where you are as far as babka goes but
if you could find like a Jewish deli
that has babka I might go there before I
go to Trader Joe's but maybe the Trader
Joe's chocolate babka is fine
I mean I've already tried it is
excellent of the highest order I must
say so I imagine I imagine the Jewish
deli would be otherworldly in other
words so maybe so yeah but listen it's
it's good it's good if you can find it
at all I think that's a good start yeah
definitely definitely
um but on to my next question uh just
given all of this sort of atmosphere
that we have in this country and Trump's
announcement on Tuesday yep
um
just with everything going on and this
is very sort of philosophical esoteric
question
um my favorite type of question
yeah
um how much time do you think we've
bought American democracy just in terms
of the election and Trump's announcement
you're saying with his announcement how
much time we bought
well just the totality of it the
election and and his announcement and
just the general political sort of
atmosphere I mean listen I don't for me
it's so the results of the midterms to
some degree
are reassuring although Republicans are
still taking the house and they almost
took the Senate but they didn't and you
know it's going to be two years of
gridlock but to some degree at least
enough people cared about the outcome to
hold off an actual Red Wave
on the other hand with Trump's
announcement Trump's announcement itself
was pretty dystopian but what I'm a
little bit reassured by is how boring
everybody in the room found it and how
in all the polling that's recent Trump
seems to be losing in most of the polls
to DeSantis who hasn't even announced
its candidacy so I have like a small
cautious optimism that the Republican
party is ready to be done with Trump
yeah I'm hopeful I had to actually tune
away from his his announcement because I
just I was falling asleep it was
incredible it was a lot of the same
stuff he's been doing at the rallies but
presented in a more boring monotone
combined with I'm running for president
it was very strange very very strange
yeah I'm not I'm not quite sure yeah
um do you think that like if Trump loses
in the primaries to DeSantis or somebody
else do you think he's going to keep
claiming fraud or do you think he's
gonna pivot somehow I hope that he runs
as an independent if that happens just
because it would be so terrible for the
Republican party I don't I'm not you
know kind of holding my breath but it
would be amazing for for Trump to just
run as an independent take like 15
percent of the Republican vote and
prevent the Republican nominee from
winning that would be great
yeah you you definitely have a point
there I hope he does too well that's all
I had then Tristan didn't remind me of
your blindness tell me about it are you
I just don't remember are you completely
blind
I am completely blind and both eyes have
been since I was born yeah so you this
is if I I know that this is not new
ground but like if I say to you that
like the background of my set is blue
does that have any meaning to you
uh yeah I mean like so just throughout
my lifetime I've just kind of been able
to contextualize what colors are I
remember like asking my dad what is
black like what is red like and you know
red is like the bright
you know sort of you know I remember
being on you know describing it while I
was engaged in some substances like man
it's like it's like you're it's loud to
the eyes and you know blue is kind of
like it's softer but it has a bright
color it's hard it's interesting they
have some meaning to me but it it it it
can it can be a little tricky but and
and yeah and so you have no idea what I
look like right
not really no I mean I know you've
described yourself a little bit but I
don't have any idea what you look like
now interesting very very interesting
wow uh well Tristan listen I appreciate
you calling in and uh we're gonna keep
an eye it sounds like you and I are
keeping an eye on a lot of the same
things so I appreciate it all right
thanks so much David you take care you
too there is Tristan from Oregon great
to hear from him let's go uh why don't
we go next I mean why not right let's go
to Bryce from Scotland Bryce welcome
can you hear me fine you sound like
you're completely underwater your audio
is totally muddled
okay uh I will do my best to try oh
that's a little better
oh God yeah
oh boy second
well what was your question Bryce let's
see if we can understand each other
[Music]
uh right I'll do I'll do my best yeah uh
not trying to be too pessimistic but um
do you think there's
a way at all obviously you've probably
seen the joke that UK Paul takes is at
the minute
with three prime ministers in seven
weeks
sorry what's happening in seven weeks
Bryce
oh sorry uh let me
I am impressed I'm gonna let you go for
now just because the the audio is it's
it's not maybe it's me I might be having
an issue
but um I'm gonna let you go for now and
let's see if we can let's see if we can
reset uh let's try uh oh I don't know
how about Nate from Rhode Island what's
going on Nate
hey David how you doing I'm doing well
so I had a question for you it's not as
mainstream but it's about the Second
Amendment so now the first uh sentence
of the Second Amendment states uh about
a regulation of wall regulator militia
does that mean we can regulate them to
the point of like Japan for instance
like and not not to say that I doubt
this quote credit Court wouldn't strike
it down but what do you think about that
no so the a lot of those semantics
Second Amendment arguments have all kind
of been explored and and they're just
kind of retreads so I I don't know the
answer to that there it's not where I
would be focusing my activism on gun
safety regulation I would be focusing on
let's do the things we know we can do
that don't depend on the linguistic
um uh nuances of how it's written and
instead say like we gotta eliminate the
possibility of any gun sales without a
background check we've got to limit high
capacity magazines you know we have this
full list I would focus there instead of
on these linguistic concerns okay well
thank you I just had that thought in my
head for a little while and wanted to
get that out thank you so much for
taking my call appreciate it very much
let's take a very quick break we're
going right back to the phone so if
you're holding on to talk to me don't
hang up and we'll get back in just a
minute
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikoto website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your and and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below